that's good is this your own game that
you saw yeah [__] entrepreneurs man
that's good because that [__] cards
became Manatee great concept but God is
a bad execution yeah we took it to the
next level those [__] cards are dumb
dude yes
this is the next level did you write
that well this is either us or all of
our fans it's like 10 years of
crowdsourcing good work
[Music]
would you rather lose half your dick's
length or half your dick's girth I mean
I'm killing myself instantly
I can't
I
kill love either
[Laughter]
barely hanging on
I guess if oof
dude that's a tough penis either way
anyways
my dig would be basically a Twizzler at
this point if I lost half the girth
damn but I couldn't go all right let's
see let's do the math here I feel like
uh barely three inches regular girth
versus just a just a a slim six
it's not what you want either way I
can't I'm sorry are there more doors or
wheels in the world that's the big one
that went viral recently oh for real
yeah yeah with two wheels on the car but
usually two to four doors you also got
little things like the gas tank door but
then you got oh [__] oh [__] I mean God
damn it I love
I love you like I
win I'll give you 200 but if the Rams
when I get to cut your hair your hair
and he didn't think it through he
thought I wanted to cut his hair he was
10 years old and I [__] this kid's
head up the first thing I did I cut his
bangs like simple Jack and he looked at
me and he goes does it look cool No
[__] I'm [__] you up so that's what
you gotta that's why you gotta do the
math that's how you get into the math on
this I'm going I'm going Wheels can you
still go to your Barber if he is very
racist I don't know a barber that's not
a little racist
why were they like the most strongly
opinionated [__] on the face of
the Earth and anybody with a strong
opinion has some Choice words to say
about certain people from certain
regions so I'm gonna say yeah absolutely
in fact I encourage it please be racist
you know I understand this question
though because this is a very white
question this question is this question
is kind of racist because you guys think
you're the only ones that can be racist
uh
yeah for sure please be racist would you
rather always come from me Charlie or
never not at all definitely always come
prematurely and the more often the
better
um you know every 10 seconds as a guy
like if a guy comes prematurely you're
okay with it oh yeah yeah I never want a
guy to not come at all like I need that
it's gratification okay it's like not so
it's not long enough for you to get off
I don't care it's fine we can just go
again like it's fine give me a second
every time he's only good for a minute
it's fine I honestly still rather that
than a guy who like first of all never
comes at all or it takes a long time to
come like I still feel very much the
same I saw someone posted that video the
other day and said is this satire and
I'm like no I'm 100. um I did someone
similar to this like would you rather a
guy lost last 50 seconds or like I
remember when you say short guys and the
short Kings United and [__] himself
short Kings no and now there's like a
movement with shark Kings you see I was
ahead of that I was ahead of that if you
could be a master at one of the four
bases of sex but you'd have to be below
average at every other base I think what
are the bases yeah I think we're both
pretty good at eating [__] and that's
it and we are below average in every
other day I would excel at sucking
titties dude just be nastiest yeah
that's crazy you mentioned that I've
gotten into that it's the best I'm big
into sucking tits how long do you suck
the tits for as long as you want yeah
a girl just lays there like
it's a bathtub I'll look up like the fat
baby
don't worry babe I got you and then I'll
start sucking the other one she's like
my nipples are actually they hurt you've
chafed them do you like do you like do
you latch
[Laughter]
yeah yeah dude Logics and [__] okay
well you you just recently got a child
you must be running into some
some nip holes bro yeah I'm patiently
waiting my return I don't want to cross
wires yeah exactly exactly yeah I don't
want to show her what's good you're
gonna have the baby have the baby who
also has your DNA would you rather leave
a date with a hot chick for 10 minutes
to take a [__] or hold it in and hope
for the best I would rather [__] on my
date I'd leave her for 10 minutes I'd
leave her for dude how about this one
time you ready for this one time is that
the comedy style in New York City I
beautiful girl took her on a date to the
comedy tell her I'm like hey just wait
up here I gotta go downstairs do my set
15 minutes set easy breezy I come up
she's gone I was like I saw a lot of
waitresses I was like where's the girls
with just with she goes oh she left with
uh Aziz Ansari I was like wow wow this
[__] took my day dude and then I
[__] went home and I I jerked off to
Masters of none
I talked to him about it he's you know
claims he doesn't no he doesn't yeah
he's like oh I don't even know man I'm
sorry I was just doing something you
know would you rather never have any
buffalo sauce food ever again or only be
able to masturbate to pregnant porn that
yikes yeah that's a good one
that's like somebody from the CIA wrote
that oh man that's tough this is all
like this is on a job application at
Google
the right [__] one
I'd lose the Buffaloes I love buffalo
sauce but if you pregnant porn just
creeps me out I feel bad for those
expecting mothers
I respect there's four women
it's working mom dude would you be
celibate for a year to be able to have
sex with any girl you wanted after the
year was up yes a hundred percent yes
yes yes yes and I think you know who it
would be for the best no you wouldn't
have such a Taylor Swift would you I'm
not going to say yes because I don't
want to like that's like rude to her if
she doesn't want it but but it's also
rude if you say no yes yes you think so
more than anyone you think that she's
like kinky and like good in bed or you
just want to do it because I'm like hold
her you're such a [__] weirdo okay I
swear
you're gay for Taylor I really love her
a lot and I would and I would but I
would do only if she wanted to obviously
I feel bad even answering that question
and you're ruining my Champion Wendy
stay in the bedroom with you during sex
yep
she does and we have two dogs that have
to leave and two dogs that are allowed
to stay
because all behaviors are not over here
no um it's all about the the hunger for
semen and we have one dog that is so
utterly addicted to semen that like as
I'm doing it the dogs literally jamming
his nose I mean straight up this dog
loves come so much it's trying to get it
straight from the tap
I mean I was literally trying to Bone
I've got the dogs to his nose up my ass
and that's not even that's not hyperbole
that's not exaggeration that dog has to
go yeah
100 would you rather [__]
a chick who's banged a thousand dudes or
a chick who's banged one animal
come on dude
one animal
there's antibiotics would you rather hey
watch your dad [__] a hundred year old
man or B watch your mother kill someone
can I have both is there any way I can
do both
um at the same time
um I think I would rather my mother kill
someone because I think my mother
probably wants to kill some people and
uh I just think it'd be fun because I'd
launched I kind of I think should be
good at it you know and my dad [__]
100 year old man it just feels dangerous
for both of them so I'm gonna go with
watch my mom kill someone and if I could
pick the woman that would be our man
whoopsie
um who was the one person in the world
you would least want to bang your
significant other
I mean that kind of already happened to
me
you always send me up aren't you yeah
damn pulling on the heartstrings
we're the top five mils of all time
Sophia Vergara is number one beyond that
it's gonna be a little bit like I'm a
blend I don't want to put them in exact
order at least Anne's up there Kendra
yes she's not okay okay
speak no no no no no no no you know what
we're going to keep it we're gonna keep
it with people without kids all right
we'll scrap we'll scratch her Brandy
Love does have a kid I've met them so
she counts so that's two there's Kendra
lost to have a kid anyone know by the
way Kendra Lust has one child has a kill
I'll put it on the board is Jennifer
Aniston she have a kid yeah [__] dude so
if you have regards number one number
two would be sharing a coal number three
Kendra Lust
Sharon Nicole is at us and Ray's mom
just just for anyone who didn't know
yeah yeah
yeah I'm gonna put Heidi demilio up
there as well she's bad but me and Mark
are boy so it's all good Mark Emilio
shout out to you bro I'm gonna see you
next week
and then number five
um
goodness man
Jane Fonda
wow what would you choose if you could
only have one for the rest of your life
well I'm not I don't have a dick so not
blow jobs
um regular sex or anal that is [__]
hard because I [__] love anal and
like I still love like it's like very
much a present thing in my life it's not
something that it's like I abandoned it
in a past like it's like something
that's like very much like there and
present very sexual and okay I guess I
can still squirt with regular sex so
I'll keep regular sex and judge that you
know like I mean I gotta be able to have
one either squirting or but yeah at
least with regular sex I'll have like
vaginal orgasms even though I won't have
anal orgasms and I also get to squirt
but I can't Square for me you know so
that's the thing then I'll lose
squirting too who's the worst group of
fans people who believe in Bitcoin
Bitcoin bro Bitcoin people on Twitter oh
my God
I've never I have I've gone at the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia nobody goes
harder than people who believe in
Bitcoin on Twitter
would you rather a sit on a cake and eat
a dick or B sit on a dick and eat a cake
B obviously sit on a dick and eat a cake
oh yesterday
that's called my birthday
would you rather [__] that first of all
I want to prove this language but okay
internet would you rather [__] the
hottest girl celebrity who has a dick a
man or Vin Diesel with a [__]
I [__] do the dick chick
yeah Vin Diesel's too emotional he'd
want to cuddle you know that dick chick
would be like all right
get him put a dick on it [__] like if
it was your choice be who would I put a
regular female celebrity add a dick to
it yeah it's like a Margot Robbie um
who's Wonder Woman uh Gail Gadot yes
[__] wouldn't be a hawk it wouldn't be
like she wouldn't be like mess with the
[__] thing you know yeah
nice piece yeah like shriveled [__]
Thailand dick yeah no she'd have a nice
piece you think so nice helmet Israeli
should have big balls
who cares we roll the dice we'd have
some dice you made that's what I go if
you're with Galvin now you'd be like
let's just go remember that movie uh
Rockstar with Mark Wahlberg and the next
day and he banged that chicken she's
pissed and standing up come on every guy
in the theater had a place popcorn on
the lap
could you beat Tom Cruise in a fight
absolutely not that's my hero and I
don't fight Heroes all right I'm Goose
he's always Maverick
this question I don't think we've ever
asked it to a lesbian it totally takes a
whole new form but it works would you
rather [__] the most hideous girl in the
world or an average looking guy
this is like the perfect question for
Jessica oh my God this is so hard
it's gonna sound horrible I mean what
does hideous mean hideous is like you
are like literally a troll under a
bridge you know what I mean like almost
borderline disfigured you know average
looking guy
if you could have anyone in history on
plug talk who would you pick oh for sure
we're including the dead right Audrey
Hepburn Audrey
yeah you want to experience some of that
classic [__] that there's like nobody
on record even like rating or evaluating
it right well you know what Nancy Reagan
after that yeah was she hot apparently
Nancy Reagan is what they call the
throat goat of Hollywood back in the day
really sucked everybody's dick and was
like the queen I want that Monica
Lewinsky top too and I want to see Bill
before he does so I can I could be like
hey bro me and you for ten thousand
dollars would you spend two days
carrying around a human looking Japanese
robot yes that you had to introduce to
people as your girlfriend
yeah what a ten thousand dollars dude
yeah I agree with you I'm sorry I can't
even believe the question yeah what kind
of a [__] Rich [__] this wouldn't
do this for 10 grand in two days that's
five grand a day to just have fun for a
little bit of people I honestly don't
think I'm gonna oh shut the [__] up what
are you talking about
dude you said you bought the jaw
strengthening thing to build out your
jaw because Instagram
all right well we don't think it's gonna
be [__] on Instagram advertising you're
gonna get bot also you never had like a
fox
yeah dude you will be the first one into
the breach yeah I'm so you don't stand a
chance I'm so upset with his behavior
right now
30 seconds
dude you're [__] you're gonna come
home in your head you're like I hope my
[__] hole three thousand is alert and
charged
yeah you're gonna have fun in the next
decade if your dad and your boyfriend
switched bodies oh boy I'm the only way
to get them back to normal is to bang
one of them which one would you [__] I
think I'm gonna have to [__] my dad's
body with my boyfriend's brain my dad
he's a large man so I don't think that
the penis would be fully insert you know
that is wild I got a big belly it
probably won't be too much contact
I don't know bacon or sausage oh this is
some [__] how dare you I think it's
easy I think
bacon oh no no sir no bacon I have to go
no bacon I have to go over bacon because
you know what it sizzles imagine not
having bacon bacon and eggs sausage and
eggs sausage egg and cheese on a bagel I
mean come on would you rather spend the
rest of your life in a country music
video or rap music video well that's
easy because country music there you
know they're like in the fields doing
their [__] it's all white people in rap
music listen there's nothing better on
this planet than a fat ass let's be
honest fellas I'm on a yacht I got
chains on undressed exactly how I am now
I got cool sneakers chains tats [__]
boats cars basically are pretty [__]
close my life's pretty much a rap video
yeah but I'm married with two kids if
you could have anyone in history on plug
talk who would you pick oh for sure
we're including the dead right Audrey
Hepburn Audrey
Monroe yeah you want to experience some
of that classic [__] that there's like
nobody on record even like rating or
evaluating it right well you know what
Nancy Reagan after that yeah was she hot
apparently Nancy Reagan is what they
call the throat goat of Hollywood back
in the day really sucked everybody's
dick and was like the queen I want that
Monica Lewinsky top too and I want to
see Bill before he does so I can I could
be like hey bro me and you is jerking
off to nudes of a girl who has died nice
sorry weird or nice tribute you can tell
this listen to me you can tell this was
written by a man because only dudes on
Reddit threads are like oh a trivia it's
not a [__] tribute even if she's
alive it's [__] gross your jizz is
not an honor
that being said it depends on how hot
she is
if you go back in time and give one
piece of advice to yourself what it
would it be this is real as [__] is
something Andrew Schultz said to me
years ago he said the moment you are
immune to rejection you are unstoppable
go ask every girl out that you think is
cute and if she says no who gives a [__]
it's actually hilarious that a girl says
you're not good enough to date me it's
so funny it's great good for you now you
know move on ask another girl she says
no who cares you're fine get rejected
fail all the time and learn from it and
the better you handle the rejection I
remember I was uh before I met my wife I
wasn't even trying to I was just trying
to like get better at talking to girls I
would get rejected by girls and be so
like unfazed by it and think it was so
funny that sometimes it flipped them
because it happened a couple times it
was like I was like I would just be like
I get it you know what I mean or
whatever I would just be as funny as I
could with it and then weirdly it
flipped them a couple times would you
rather have one giant what is the one
thing someone can say that makes you
immediately hate them
um
the n word
two buttons you can only press one a
instantly get a million dollars or B
have a 50 50 chance you get 100 million
dollars yeah we're gonna up the one
million for you though let's say it's
yeah for me no because I'll be honest
with you I am so [__] Rich no this
wouldn't even affect me it wouldn't
affect me that's why I couldn't do this
internet [__] for nothing it's like
you're not paying me so I don't give a
[__] I don't press any button I don't
need your [__] million 10 million or
a shot at 100. I'll take the 10 million
I'll just press the button take the 10
million and go home because I have no
when would you switch over no because I
have an investment can't talk about it
right now sure
um it's in Bitcoin I have an nft
have you guys heard of these nfts I know
that I could take 10 million and within
hours I could turn it into the 100
million very good when it comes to
investing you get arrested
happy each other oh who's gonna pick up
who's not gonna give you a hard time
about it who's reliable who's sober and
reliable
[Laughter]
I call you what the [__] you actually
probably wouldn't answer will you be in
jail with me I would always answer big
cat
what do you see in town that week
I've actually never talked to big kids
who the [__] would I call realistically
and and I have to call a Barstow
employee that everybody knows I'm gonna
probably go Kelly
she's like an older sister talking she
would she and she's home oh I'm calling
Kate okay I'm calling Kate you gonna
make her do that yeah she would in a
heartbeat and she'd burn cash she'd
bring cash yeah I'm gonna cash the value
out or casual kid uh both
okay you can only have one oh God I hate
these questions only one okay six inches
oh God okay six feet six figures six
feet
because remember we don't need the six
inch dick and I at this point I'm making
six figures now so it's fine
with only fans I'm good to go that's
fine there it is who's the best fat
athlete of all time would it be the
fridge who are you thinking of Warren
Sapp is a good one yeah but he's like
what do we considering fat here are we
talking like okay is butter bean in the
equation yeah you know what I mean like
butter beans you got Haynesworth but he
was lazy yeah Ainsworth haysworth was
like until he got fat and then he got
bad yeah I I tell you what the Warren
Sap would be tough to beat I think
Warren Sapp and all the his little
combine like he always hit the Pro Bowl
stuff all the little agile drills like
Warren Sapp is a monster would you
rather a [__] yourself every time you
come or be get a boner every time you
talk to a dude yeah I'd just be get a
boner every time I talk to him yeah
usually early morning flights that's a
boner for like three hours yeah you ever
get an uncontrollable long bonus long
flights early morning drives
yeah getting the car yeah I don't have
no problem having a bonus no problem
yeah it's a boner boner talk message I
mean that was all of high school I
talked to dudes while having a boner the
entire time
there was no problem in fact think of
all the conversations you and your boys
were both erect on a lot of them some of
my Fondest Memories dude me and my boys
hard as hell chopping it up chopping it
up it was always great when there was a
kid who didn't know the tuck method true
who didn't know the TalkBack dorks yeah
like when the teacher would be like come
up and present and they were like I
don't want to but if it's gym day you
got the sweatpants in a Catholic school
and then you might protrude the
sweatpants that's [__] dude it's a
helmet dude I've told this I've told you
this one time it was uh it was in eighth
grade and we were lifting for football
and I had a bonus in the weight room so
I talked to it with my gym shorts then
it was my turn to bench so I laid down
and my shirt came up
with the tip of my upside down penis was
sticking out and my friend who was
spotting was like Shane's penis is out
and everyone had a good laugh all right
and then I repped 225.
no it was over I mean that was a long
time ago that was shot who you are today
probably it was the upside down yeah
you see the curve yeah
that dude's reaction uh Shay's penis
[Laughter]
hey it's just creeping out of your no
fear shirt
just
flaring over the [__] CD player
trying to take on anyone
should you lock a dog out of the room
when you're having sex okay
so I have a cat
love my cat cat's name is Piper when
it's go time when it's time for the
fiance to hop on a maximum ride love
Piper to death Piper's going out the
door because it gets loud it gets sweaty
and it's not a safe environment for any
pet what's one thing Tom could do that
would make you consider killing him oh
[__] easy and I tell him this all the
time I'm like if you bang another female
comic I'll [__] murder you okay
[__] oh my God like if he bangs
anyone like a groupie or something like
I would murder him but if he banged a
female comic I'll [__] I'll rip his
dick off and I'd stab him in the [__]
chest
if I wouldn't go to jail would you
rather live your life as is or be a
billionaire but you have to blow a dude
every day who am I blowing that's an
important part let's say he is just like
the most average dude most average dude
suburbs he's an average guy he's like
41. yeah drives like a Honda Odyssey for
the kids he's like not in good shape not
in bad shape and is it the same guy
every day the same guy he shows up and I
blow him you're like hi hey Jeff Jeff
how long does it take him to come here
you are sucking dick oh yeah I guess it
would get better over time and like
learn his Kinks and stuff
oh yeah and I'm making him come like
crazy I think I I take the billionaire I
suck a dick every day because one I
don't have to worry about anything but
the worst thing in my life is sucking
dick but also I'm probably getting like
a really good friend out of this
like this guy's gonna be my friend for
like ever like we're gonna have cities
yeah we're like yo let's get this done
yeah and he [__] comes and I suck his
dick and then we'll like we hang on we
talk a little bit I'm like hey dude good
to see you good to see you the only
shitty thing would be is like if I
wanted because you're a billionaire
you're gonna travel and do [__] I gotta
take him with me if there was a snail
following you for the rest of your life
and if you touched it you die
how long could you survive and it's it's
Immortal it goes itself okay because I'm
not trying I'm not trying to uh
hypothetical my way out of the
hypothetical yeah you know what I'm
saying so he'll never stop he can cross
oceans he can fly I Will Survive till
the day I died you think so I was I
would die like if this was the only
thing that could kill me I would die of
natural causes there's no [__] way to
Spell's gonna catch me I feel like
because you never know though you lay
down at night you're like the snail is
not like well you you just look you just
you just got to be on you just gotta be
on your [__] purpose you know
what I'm saying you got to get up every
day and run a mile that gives you at
least 48 hours
you know just gotta keep going yeah I
mean you move everything you know it's
like yeah you got to keep going you got
to be constantly aware of what this
[__] is yeah do you think
you think that that Chanel takes credit
right at 60 of stress he's like I got it
yeah I mean
my problem my problem would be you know
one day I'm like severely depressed and
I turn around and just start running
back towards the snail you know what I
mean just [__] it just just touch me bro
can you lock a dog out of the room when
you're having sex yes absolutely also I
have a 70 pound pit bull if we don't
lock him out of the room it's no longer
a twosome okay he gets involved all of a
sudden he sees me trying to stab his mom
like it's not good I get a wet nose
places yes lock your dog out of the out
it's that don't don't your dog doesn't
want to see that would you really can
projectile vomited on by a homeless
person for an hour straight or get your
dick sucked by a toothless homeless
person with no gag reflex yeah this is
interesting so I'm trying again I'm
trying to do the math here about why I
wouldn't get my dick sucked diseases
Maybe gross a rotted out mouth I'm
exposing myself to homeless germs anyway
I might as well get a nut off yeah
yeah
if you had to watch one category of porn
for the rest of your life what would it
be
um yeah I'm so I mean I'm amateur I used
to go to Reddit homemade XXX so that I I
got shown that and it it opened my eyes
to a world
and then I stood on that for a long time
and now I'm like kind of for ease I go
to PornHub just because you know I'm
jerking between naps of my son he's like
out for 10 seconds and then I hear his
cars on the floor and I'm like gotta
finish so it's whatever I put my mouse
over and it looks good Latina amateur
casting couch
you know yeah when it's crunch time I
know exactly who I'm giving the ball to
if you could see a sex tape with any two
movie characters who would it be let's
say Newman and Kramer from Seinfeld and
then
yeah yeah and I would also like Jerry to
walk in and he goes hello Jerry there
are more murderers What a Sad group
would you rather live in colonial times
or you're 2500 well I know what they did
to my people in colonial time so
2500. I'm going back with these guns
since colonial times I promise you that
much if I went back in time to Colonial
times I doubt they had 6-1 Indian dudes
back in there left and right hooks how
many grown men would it take to kill a
grizzly bear with their bare [__]
hands
honestly dude the only grown man I know
that could kill a grizzly bear is TT
Jerry and he's a woman I'm not even
trying to be funny I really think like
somebody's job maybe two of the guys
jobs would be to try to de-escalate that
bear and try to jerk it off a little bit
try to make it come so I like gets I I
think that's the only way you have to
get a little sexual with it start
figuring its ass a little bit you have
to because it's just gonna [__] I think
it could just keep swiping people one
after another you know that's what I do
dude unless it's the purge is Eiffel
towering a chick with another guy gay an
Eiffel Tower is like so I'm behind he's
in the front and we just [__] high
five no it's not gay if we've learned
anything from the TV show Euphoria
anything goes now dude Anything Goes
it's just banging what would you say uh
you know like
a good old-fashioned DP is two two balls
together with a guy that's probably a
little bit uh homo erotic it's
definitely homoerotic two two dicks
going into the same hole I think the
only thing
I think that's the clinical definition
of gay
I think I don't think threesomes with
two guys and a girl is gay unless the
guys start doing [__] to each other yeah
I don't think you start sucking the
dude's dick that's gay that's gay if you
start enjoying it yeah
if you're like [__] yeah let me just let
me just Flex a little bit to make it
stronger so he feels they're going this
guy to feel as good as I feel right now
you're totally straight away you start
pushing the blood there even more
it's gay
but there's nothing wrong with that no
there's nothing wrong with that
everybody would you rather be known as
the best sex ever by a bunch of normal
girls or the worst sexover ever by a
bunch of smokes
the smokes mean like hot women I feel
like I'm 50 years old no I'm too
insecure I want to I want first of all
Noble girl is hot for me I'm not exactly
you know kicking ass out there folks I
mean I'm married my wife's beautiful
whatever uh but yeah I'm gonna go best
sex ever which is pretty closer to the
truth
how much money would it take for you to
not drink for a year
17 sex robots
I did a week and that's pretty [__]
and they paid you and they paid you 450
yeah still did it don't [__] minimize
my ability you got paid to be sober yeah
and you took mushrooms halfway that's
the question that's the question you'd
have to put me in like Bali but then as
soon as I hit the sand I pre-fucking
searching for cocktails behind your back
I'd be paying off every shady dude in
the corner yeah
let me get a little I'd be snorting
Daiquiri I wouldn't give a [__] how I
got in my system not a shot yeah suck my
dick with that is jerking off to webcam
girls cheating no
no
let's all bug if you were gay for a day
who would you want to bang
I don't even think I would have to be
gay to want to bang Ryan Reynolds
right
s Brad Pitt to me
he's open guy yeah he's the gold
standard especially
like uh in the movie Seven
in order for you to live you have to
kill a blind child who has the greatest
voice of our generation are you killing
the kid yes of course I'm gonna kill the
kid because at that point it's me and
him and I'm more valuable to myself than
he is to me well I feel like I can also
lend to something to society I don't
think I'm not going to be down on myself
and think that I have to kill myself so
this kid could live there's gonna be
other blind kids that want to say [__]
which are their sacred days when you
refuse to masturbate
um I would I would say that uh funerals
tragedies I once went and this is this
is a feat all of eighth grade
all of eighth grade because or maybe it
was seven whatever it was after I had
been bar mitzvahed it turns out in the
Jewish religion that uh you're a man
after you've been in bar mitzvid so I
was like I really got to give this up
and so I didn't do it for a year and
then
um
but then but it turned out it wasn't
Prime there was a time where I would
even have a a a a a harder sex drive
where I wasn't able to resist and I and
I finally I finally I finally gave in
and the other thing was and then when I
started going in again I would just
apologize to God profusely after I
finished it was like I I don't know what
it's happening I made that promise I've
broken it because I I yeah I I have this
this is
just this old yeah this Old Testament uh
relationship with God where I'm just
apologizing all the time if you were on
an old episode of room Raiders what
would you be most afraid of being fat
being found okay in my room probably
like my dirty underwear for sure that
would be the first thing I would look to
embarrass someone and I just feel like
there have been times where men have
been alone in my house and I've had this
real moment all the time chicks dirty
underwears or a [__] Fiasco dude a
chick's dirty underwear it looks like
when it's on it looks like Spider-Man
got to it it's crazy it is wild it's too
much I'm like what happened to me
should I call the police every day I
take my underwear off and I go am I okay
too much
going on
I'm like this thing's gonna mold
[Laughter]
cut that it was the one white person
that black people would pick in
Chappelle Show racial draft I absolutely
know this answer Tom Brady Tom Brady he
doesn't he doesn't try too hard to be
anything that he's not but he's still
the coolest [__] on Earth we'll
talk mad [__] to any person regardless
of race that's the guy dude I feel like
Steve Nash had a little bit of that
Eminem does not Eminem is great at rap
but I don't think I'm like that's that
cool that's the cool white boy but
that's a white boy Brady transcends if
every time you got a boner the same song
would start playing what song would you
want I want like uh Frank Sinatra The
Way You Look Tonight
yeah yeah yeah so then it's like it's
already horny yeah yeah just the way you
look
tonight so every time that I get a boner
it's like damn well everyone's ready you
know preparation
all right all right Bill The Way You
Look Tonight by Frank Sinatra would you
rather your girlfriend oh
sorry would you rather your boyfriend be
able to read your thoughts during sex or
all the time except during sex oh [__]
I'll never thinking anything good I'd
rather be able to read during sex have
be able to read me during sex
I mean
I think I'd rather it's sex because I
would well then I just pee in my head
all the time don't think anything bad
don't think anything's bad but then
you'd have to be paranoid for all the
time just be like think good things
think good things I think like when I'm
having sex is like the only time I
really like my boyfriend
[Laughter]
outgoing sex
one time it was um
do you ever think that people can read
your mind so you start saying something
in your head and we say the same thing
in our head and we we do that yeah we
both think that people can read our
minds sometimes and then we both say
apple banana
he came to this conclusion like we
didn't even know this
yes banana banana I was like are you
[__] with me right now I'm like are
you [__] with me I'm like I know this
is like a crazy thought and like I'm
probably [__] with me but like I
think I'm a banana yeah I just think
bananas bananas bananas bananas yeah
that's crazy if your guy had to wear a
mascot head during sex for the rest of
your life which one would you choose a
mascot like for a sports team sports
people or like you know like Tony the
Tiger Tony tiger are hot yes hot yeah
actually wait no I want to change my
answer the Ninja Turtles the new Ninja
Turtles are hot
yeah I do I do the new age version I was
um they're sexy yes I was um on a date
with a guy and I told him that I think
the new Ninja Turtles are hot and he was
mortified and he was like I don't
understand what you're saying I was like
they are sexy Turtles and I don't know
why we need to talk about the store like
Jessica Rabbit huh
they're normal humans exactly Turtles
but they're like Buffs have you seen
them you want like because you want like
a [__] big right yeah yeah just like
a guy yeah just pick me up
would you rather get paid one million
dollars a year but have to work
ridiculous hours
or get 1 000 sorry 100 000 a year for
doing nothing 100 000 a year for doing
nothing I know it's great for women to
be independent and I love working and
all this [__] but if I could get 100K to
like sit and diddle myself all day
absolutely if you could see a sex tape
with any two movie characters who would
it be let's say Newman and Kramer from
Seinfeld and then yeah yeah and I would
also like Jerry to walk in and he goes
hello Jerry if you can make any two
people fight in a no rules cage match
who would you choose uh the mountain
from uh yeah and then uh Mike Tyson
would you rather [__] your dream girl
from high school or go back in time and
change your worst childhood Sports loss
to a win I hate to be mean the dream
girl in high school you see now looks
like a bag of hot dogs
you grow up and you're like oh [__]
no I [__] my dream girl in high school
damn yeah hold on if you're in high
school and you're you're actually
achieving this goal that's not really
your dream girl that's just attainable
girl we're talking someone that you
couldn't possibly touch if you had sex
with her she's not your dream girl in
school you [__] her you did
yeah yeah damn Chris up top that's
pretty rare that's pretty [__] right
yeah it's not all good news
some bad things happened in between yeah
I change a loss Archbishop Ryan yeah
Monsignor Bonner we were undefeated we
were favorites to win the Catholic
League Championship I hit a ball in the
first pitch well let me guess how far
over the fence huh
that's what I'm saying these
I could have been golfing please please
when the next time we do this can it be
like 9 A.M 8 30. first of all
right I know Chris I just want to get
you guys on the air before the workout
just once
dream girl all of a sudden he's got [__]
it he's got he's got rules all of a
sudden
I gotta get out of here if you could
have any SNL Alum as a drinking buddy
for one night who would it be
oh that's a good one you know who would
be honestly it'd be Eddie Murphy and
here's why because Eddie I don't know if
you ever met him but he's he's very kind
of like reserved if you ever see him in
interviews he doesn't really give you
much you know he makes sure he he knows
how to be famous you know what I mean so
I imagine getting really really drunk
with Eddie Murphy he'd have the most
insane hilarious stories it'd probably
be awesome I think Eddie Murphy is six
drinks away from being my best friend
come on let's do it Ed there was a snail
following you for the rest of your life
if you touched it
am I [__]
if there was a snail following you for
the rest of your life and if you touched
it you'd die how long could you survive
this is another internet classic meaning
it has like a thirst for blood wants to
kill you it can it can like it will go
to the airport it will hop on a plane it
knows you know where you are but it's
got to get to you and obviously it just
moves at the pace of a snail oh never I
never it would never touch me I moved
way too fast I move and by the way I
just had this conversation with my wife
in the car driving here she's like you
need to slow the [__] down but if I slow
down then my brain starts working and so
I don't slow down at all if you keep
moving your brain doesn't get to go one
day it goes black and you die is there
any athlete you would be okay with
[__] your wife Serena Williams
I've been thinking about this a lot
lately I've been thinking about DK
Metcalf
is what that would do to me
like the devastating because think about
oh yeah think about all the guys think
about all those poor Ole Miss alumni
that DK I mean DK Metcalf Metcalf it's a
horse I haven't seen him he literally
would be if you wrote down yeah this is
getting racist
[Laughter]
I mean every time I watch him play I'm
like
[Applause]
you'll see I'll be white knocking on the
couch
he would do what I would like to do he'd
probably lived there the whole time he
would it'd be like it would be like that
it'd be like you know that porno the
black one yes wait there's two boxes
I've heard of it it both look like he
came back two decades and a lady just
mid-air would you rather be drunk 24 7
or never be drunk again there's other
things I can do I guess but I don't
think I could function being drunk
you're like six beers but when I'm drunk
I'm like horny
like I just want to eat something and I
I wouldn't really get anything done like
I can't really retain information like
I'm gonna like can't show up The Debate
Club drunk I know God I would love to I
hate my partner
oh my God I hope he doesn't watch this
but he really
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out